But he does his camps it in Milwaukee when we go to Duke Roufus is,
what do you think about him fighting it loose man?
I like loose ma.
It's great fun.
I've always liked to smile.
I like him as a fighter for sure.
Yeah.
I don't know him as a person,
but as a fighter he's fucking terrifying.
Yeah.
He's,
he's super smart.
Yeah,
he's really good.
He's very versatile.
He can do everything.
Yeah.
So that's why I think it's more of a challenge than Colby.
Because most man brings more to the table strike striking power wise power.
And the,
the Colby thing though was in terms of like a marketing fight,
like I felt like that was a very good fight marketing wise.
I think they could've had that fight to stand alone.
Yeah.
You're not,
I don't wonder why they didn't do that.
They got I think,
but you know,
rather than,
it could have had that by standalone.
They didn't need John Jones and Anthony Smith.
I think Colby talks a lot of shit.
Other than that,
he doesn't just talk shit when the cameras are on.
I bet he talk shit all the time.
Like we had Kobe and camp sometimes.
And like I remember when he first started fighting and we was always cordial,
but now,
you know what I'm saying?
Like I don't even talk to him.
He,
he goes his way in a gym.
We pass each other just as awkward.
Yeah.
You know,
it's like he's talking about my homeboy,
right.
Tiring.
Danny's dog and I'm out.
Yeah.
You know,
and,
but you also know that he's gone to do that.
I knew it was going to get the fight.
I'll say this too.
Like even though I know that I'm still like happy for him,
I'm happy.
Did he was able to get to success.
He's gotten,
whether it was from talking or not,
he's still wanting to fights.
He's still beat dos Anjos yes.
Any beat those angels convincingly [inaudible] Josiah.
Yes.
So he's still one,
he talked a lot and I'm happy for him,
but if,
but I was just hoping that,
you know,
it's time to face the music.
Yeah.
You deserved his ass woman.
Well,
I think the UFC offered him Ooh,
smart.
And I think he said No.
I see.
I think he said he wants to fight Tyron and they'll like,
you're not in any position to the side.
And even though they had promised him a shot at the title before,
Ben Her said,
did you believe Dana white
ask you tweeted to him and he's to,
I love Ben.
He's the most ruthless when it comes to Twitter.
Yeah.
He's the most ruthless.
He's so honest in a hilarious to check you check under your skirt,
man.
Ben,
I'll get ya.
Ah,
it's a great fight though.
Oops.
Monetize.
And I'm not mad at the fight.
I do kind of wish that Colby was getting a shot because I want to see that fight
and I don't know if I will ever see that fight.
Tyron,
he's mad.
He doesn't like Colby.
Yeah,
he's,
he doesn't like them.
The three.
Yeah.
An angry Tyron is a scary human being.
He might be the fastest,
hardest hitting 170 pounds of that's ever lived.
Yeah.
Who the fuck is faster than Tyron?
Who the fuck hits harder?
You look at his fights with Wonderboy.
Wonderboy recognizes one of the greatest strikers in the sport ever.
The only person who got hurt and those fights was Wonderboy.
The same with,
with Darren,
till Darren tills a motherfucker on the feet.
Tyrant shut that shit up quick.
Blam one big right hand drop.
Some beats the fuck out of him.
Chokes the shit out of him.
Well,
here's the thing,
man,
is it,
you know it's coming to Yup.
Like every like you just can't prepare for it.
Yeah.
It's so fast.
You know it's coming.
You're like,
here it comes.
Here it comes.
Oh,
there it is.
Well,
you got to engage.
And the thing about Tyron too is he's intelligent and patient.
Yeah.
And he'll just,
he'll just hang around on the outside.
He'll hang around the house.
Like,
come on.
Yeah.
No,
you want to do this?
Make a mistake.
A mistake.
The Wonderboy fights,
like people were saying,
all of these fights are boring.
You have to fight Wonderboy that way.
Yeah.
How else do you fight them?
There's not another way to fight him because it's like one under the way you're
going to lose.
Yeah.
This is the way to find them.
You have to fight that way.
If you don't fight that way,
you get fucked up if you fight the way you know fucking Jake Ellenberger yeah,
yeah.
You can wheel kicked in the head.
Yeah.
You fight the way.
Um,
Hendrick's fondom yeah.
Fuck you.
Fuck you fucked up.
Yeah.
You got to fight that way.
You've got to stay on the outside.
You can't give into those faints and he's going to hit you with them.
Little pity pats and tips and taps.
Cause he's,
he's trying to tag you and touch you for the big ones coming in.
Yeah.
And he's,
he's,
he's elusive and he's clever and he's a lot quicker than you think.
He also bends at the waist like a God damn.
Kobe Woo Woo.
Yeah.
He's very good at bending at the waist and then coming back with punches.
He's a dangerous fighter and Woodley fought him the perfect way and he did it
twice and people are like,
oh,
that's boring.
But that's Wonderboy.
That's what
be exciting.
And you get fucked up or you fight in a cautious,
intelligent way and the fans,
boo.
See,
I don't see Joe.
I got you all wrong.
How so?
I thought you hated Tyra.
Why would I hate talking?
I don't know.
You know what I'm saying?
Because like everybody kind of always had higher and thinks everybody hates
time.
Yeah.
Maybe we talk now.
We never told them listen to the shit.
I'm talking about time and it's all positive.
We've never actually talked about it,
but,
um,
but it just seems like everybody wants to jump on him no matter what.
No,
not me.
No.
I,
I think he's,
if he's not the greatest welterweight of all time,
he's in the running.